hi this is pressure Locker you probably
had to memorize the times table in
school it's an arrangement of numbers
that tells you how to multiply two
numbers between 1 and 10 for example if
you wanted to take the product of 7 & 8
you would look in the seventh row and
the 8th column to get the result of 56
so here's a puzzler for you solve in 30
seconds what is the sum of the numbers
inside of a multiplication table that is
what is the sum of all the numbers that
I've drawn inside this box
give this puzzle a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution all right so I'm going to solve
this problem algebraically and then I'm
going to give you a geometric intuition
of why the formula comes about so we're
going to look for some patterns so let's
just take the first row of numbers and
let's say that if we add it up we get a
result of s we're going to eventually
compute s but for now let's just say
that some of the numbers from 1 to 10 is
s since every number in the second row
is twice every number in the first row
the sum of the numbers in the second row
will be 2 times s similarly every number
in the third row is 3 times every number
in the first row so the sum of the
numbers in the third row is 3 s this
pattern will continue and each row will
be a multiple of the sum of the numbers
in the first row so we can sum up all
the numbers inside the table and write
it in terms of the sum of the number in
the first row the sum of all the numbers
will be the sum s times all these
multiples one to 10
but then s is equal to the sum of the
numbers from 1 to 10 so therefore we end
up with in the sum of the numbers from 1
to 10 squared is the sum of all the
numbers inside the box so how are we
going to sum the numbers from 1 to 10
there's a formula if you sum the numbers
from 1 to N the answer is n times n plus
1 over 2 you may remember this formula
or you can click on the formula and I
presented a kind of funny way how you
could get this presented in a historical
fiction way including a mathematical
tournament with Gauss so if you apply
this formula for 10 the sum of the
numbers from 1 to 10 is 55 so we need to
square 55 to get the sum of all these
numbers there is also a trick for this
and you can click on this link you may
have seen my video to square a number
ending in 5 you take whatever values in
the tens digit or whatever leading
numbers are R multiply it by 1 more than
itself and then append 25 so I would
look at 55 squared and I would say
there's a 5 in the tens digit so I'd
multiply 5 times 6 because 6 is one more
than 5 so 5 times 6 is 30 and then I
would put 25 at the end so I'd get 30 25
is 55 squared and that's our answer so
that was the algebraic way now I want to
give you a geometric interpretation so
the number 1 in the times table is 1
times 1 we can draw this geometrically
as a square that is sides length 1 the
number 4 is 2 times 2 so we can draw
that as a square which has a side of 2
we'll draw 3 times 3 of 9 as a square
which has a side length of 3 I'm going
to proceed drawing all of the squares of
these numbers
and in general I'm going to represent
the product of two numbers X and Y as
being a rectangle with side lengths x
and y and we'll start out with the
squares so we've drawn out all the
squares in our table and now we can have
a geometric version of our x table if I
draw horizontal lines and then vertical
lines for each of these squares this is
actually a geometric x table you can
look at any two numbers and the
corresponding Square and that row in
that column will have an area will have
a area that's equal to the product of
those two numbers so now what's the sum
of all the numbers inside the
multiplication table that corresponds to
the geometric problem as what is the sum
of all these rectangles so what's the
area of the big square that we've just
created
well this square has a side length one
side is each side is the sum of the
numbers from 1 to 10 so the sum of all
the numbers inside the multiplication
table will be the sum of will be the sum
of the numbers from 1 to 10 and squared
so that'll give us the area of the big
square and the sum of all the numbers in
the x table so once again we have the
problem how do we sum up numbers from 1
to N I'll take a simpler problem let's
look at the numbers 1 2 4 if we have a
unit square which has side length 1 we
want to add up 1 we want to add up two
of them then three of them and four of
them so what's the area of the shape
well I'm going to do trick I'm going to
copy the shape and then I'm going to
rotate it and combine the two shapes so
now we've created a rectangle which has
one side length one side of 4 and
another side of 5 so the sum of the
numbers will be 1/2 of this rectangle so
the sum from 1 to 4 is 1/2 of a
rectangle with sides 4 and 5 so this
will be 4 times 5/2 which
10 we can generalize this pattern that
the sum of the numbers from 1 to n will
also end up with the rectangle that has
sides n and n plus 1 and we want half of
that so the sum of the numbers from 1 to
n will be n times n plus 1 over 2 so now
we'll wrap up the problem the sum of the
numbers up to 10 will be half of a
rectangle with side lengths 10 and 11
which is 55 and then to find the sum of
all the numbers we simply square 55
which once again gets us to 30 25 but
that's the reason we end up squaring the
numbers from the sum of the numbers from
1 to 10 is because essentially we are
finding the area of a square which has a
side length of 55 which is going from
the sum of the numbers from 1 to 10 did
you solve it thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker and if you like this video please
check out my books there are links in
the video description